ja also beim thema geht es nicht direkt
um simple sondern eher um die thematik
wie es im internationalen sport bereich
und vermutlich auch in vielen anderen
bereichen des gesellschaftlichen und
sozialen lebens aussieht und da
natürlich als sportlerin habe ich
hautnah miterlebt wie es meinen
kolleginnen vor allem letztes jahr zum
teil sogar noch in diesem jahr geht da
zum beispiel russische kolleginnen oder
chinesische kolleginnen oder eben leute
aus kasachstan oder aus staaten der
ehemaligen sowjetunion gar keine chance
haben den richtigen impfstoff zu
bekommen um dann die erlaubnis zu
bekommen in deutschland oder in anderen
eu staaten australien oder usa überhaupt
am spielbetrieb teilzunehmen und das
wiederum führt dazu dass mittlerweile
jetzt in der national viele wettbewerber
dadurch nicht mehr in der stärke und was
die besten sportler des landes angeht
durchgeführt werden und meines erachtens
macht eben diese politik weil sie eben
zu einspurig in einigen ländern ist den
sportbetrieb und natürlich auch den
gedanken des sports die vereinigung von
vielen ländern
kulturen und religionen komplett kaputt
da geht es ja um teilnahme freiheit also
eigentlich auch ein wichtiger grundsatz
ich frag mich da und dann würd mich mal
interessieren wie sie das sehen ob wir
da nicht weltweit jetzt vielleicht auch
mal eine art von neuer diskurs und
regelungen brauchen wie wir mit
hierarchien umgehen wie wir mit den
verschiedenen kategorien umgehen
überhaupt entscheidungen zu treffen denn
da müssen sich ja regierungen darüber
austauschen dann müssen sich
gesundheitsministerien austauschen das
braucht er eine ganz andere art von
struktur und natürlich sollte ich das
ziel sein von bürokratie
runterzukommen und weniger struktur
einzuziehen als jetzt noch mehr
andererseits muss es natürlich
irgendwelche mechanismen geben die man
jetzt einführt damit man sich dann neu
verständigen kann und je beispiel ist
eigentlich das beste dass wir das jetzt
brauchen das liegt ja auf der hand wie
sehen sie das natürlich brauchen wir das
und na klar liegt es auf der hand und es
gibt ja solche strukturen das ist dann
die struktur innerhalb der eu und in
australien und amerika wo man halt mit
dem falschen impfstoff oder mit dem
falschen land wo man dann den richtigen
impfstoff verimpft bekommt halt nicht
teilnehmen kann und da müsse es eine
korrespondenz zu in allen ländern dieser
welt geben und alleine schon durch die
politische lage in der wir jetzt sind
ist es ein ding der unmöglichkeit das
witzige für mich an der stelle ist das
zum beispiel jetzt in meinem bereich die
internationalen wettkämpfe in der
ehemaligen zu wetten dass in den staaten
der ehemaligen sowjetunion im osten für
jeden sportler möglich sind aha im
vergleich dazu in der eu als auch in
australien und in amerika es eben nicht
möglich ist das heißt diese drei gruppen
von ländern sind die einzigen täter
wirklich barrieren schaffen und das
finde ich eigentlich sehr sehr schade
dafür dass wir eben in einem land in
einem landwirt grundrecht mit
freiheitsrechte und so groß geworden
sind was meinen sie was sind die so sagt
die hemmschuhe oder wo geht das
eigentlich los ist es das geld oder sind
es die ideologische hintergründe sind
das sozusagen die politischen strukturen
was da eigentlich entscheidend also ich
vermutet dass es politische sachen sind
weil für mich ist es unlogisch dass man
jetzt hier sagt zum beispiel in
deutschland naja sputnik oder sie nowak
schützt nicht so sehr deswegen ist es
klar dass die leute die neben mit diesen
impfstoff geimpft wurden mit gefahr
darstellen am spielbetrieb in
deutschland teilzunehmen wenn eben in
den ländern wie zum beispiel russland
oder china die länder dann davon
überzeugt sind dass sputnik als auch
sonova gute impfstoffe sind die gegen
korona schützen dann haben wir ja
verschiedene sichtweisen und dann ist es
für mich schwer zu verstehen warum diese
eine sichtweise dann alle anderen
ausgrenzt da kannst du das
nachvollziehen warum es nicht dann
erlaubt ist oder nicht angesehen ist
beispielsweise mit stunde kämpfte zu
sein
ja das ist eine interessante frage weil
natürlich in der ukraine sichtbare bin
filmstoffe sputnik noch einmal eine ganz
andere emotionale aufladung hat nämlich
weil dieser in russland produziert
worden ist und das ganze hier natürlich
zwischen den beiden ländern hoch
emotional diese debatte geführt wird
aber ich möchte das noch aus der anderen
perspektive betrachten denn ich habe
gerade darüber nachgedacht als ihr über
corona geredet habe wie wenig ich
eigentlich in den letzten wochen über
coronas nachgedacht habe weil ich in
einem land das größere probleme hat es
nämlich vor allem krieg steht oder in
einem krieg steht und inwieweit chor
oder plötzlich keine rolle mehr spielt
aber es dann auch gar kein thema mehr
ist und ist irgendwie auch nicht so
richtig so aussieht als würde diese
gesellschaft in der ukraine zumindest
momentan von corona wahnsinnig
heimgesucht ich habe da jetzt bezahlen
oder statistiken zu weil er auch weniger
getestet weniger geimpft und so weiter
wird aber das ist mir schon in vielen
krisen ländern so gegangen in die ich
die reist bin während der korona hat
unter anderem auch in afghanistan das
plötzlich wenn etwas wichtiger wird als
büro oder das thema plötzlich wie
weggeflogen ist und ich kann euch sagen
dass gut alles gut auch wenn es hier
noch viel trennendes und schwierig ist
wie schaffen wir es dass auch in
deutschland wächst da sind sie jetzt
eigentlich wieder einer meinung das ist
wegfliegen was es muss weg fliegen und
wir leben
paul ronzheimer hat es gesagt dass sehr
viele menschen verständnis hätten für
maßnahmen das wäre in umfragen
ausgedrückt wir erleben dass nach 24
monaten
sehr viele menschen sich an die
unfreiheit gewöhnt haben und wir leben
vor allem dass ältere generation an
sagen bitte behalten die maßnahmen bei
weil sie sich vor dem virus zu fürchten
ich sage die gesellschaft ist von einer
großen nsr ruhig bei wir sind am ende
angekommen sein